[Music]  Roseanne Barr has a message for her TV  kids Sara Gilbert and Michael Fishman  I'm sorry here's what the comic tweeted  on Thursday quote I only care about  apologizing for the hurt I have  unwittingly and stupidly caused I failed  to correctly express myself and caused  pain to people adding to Michael Fishman  and Sara Gilbert  I forgive you both love you both just  wish you could have called me personally  to talk rather than do it in a public  arena I understand though it's okay  while Barr didn't specify what she was  offering forgiveness for both Gilbert  and fishman have made public statements  about the cancellation of ABC's Roseanne  revival which came Tuesday after Barr  posted and deleted a racist tweet  attacking Barack Obama's former White  House advisor Valerie Jarrett Fishman  tweeted quote the words of one person do  not exemplify the thinking of all  involved while Gilbert wrote I am  disappointed in her actions to say the  least  [Music]